Українські бійці виходять з "Азовсталі" після довгих тижнів оборони з підземелля.
Це відео російського міністерства оборони.
За даними відомства, з понеділка, 16 травня, територію металургійного комбінату залишили 1908 українських військових,
з них 80 важкопоранених.
Британська розвідка наводить цифру у близько 1700 військових,
при тому що частина бійців залишаються на заводі.
Серед десятків людей Вікторія не бачить свого брата Сашка. Але знає - він на "Азовсталі".
Йому 24 роки, він, як і Вікторія, з Маріуполя.
У грудні вступив до лав тероборони, з 24 лютого - став на захист рідного міста.
Єдиною надією для Вікторії та інших родичів бійців було залучення третьої сторони до евакуації.
Ми не наполягали навіть на військовому вирішенні цієї ситуації.
А сенс, якщо треба було діяти швидко.
Там їжа закінчувалася, вода закінчувалася.
У мене там не лише брат, у мене там друзі.
І от вони кажуть: "Ми п'ємо технічну воду".
Це, кажуть, просто неможливо, їмо раз у день, у кращому випадку.
Мені складно було за цим усім спостерігати, тому що мало того, що в тебе є страх за життя рідної людини,
тому що там щохвилини гинуть люди військові, а ти ще й розумієш, у яких пекельних умовах вони там перебувають.
Після 82 днів спротиву, 16 травня, бої на комбінаті припинилися.
Українська сторона оголосила про початок "операції порятунку" захисників "Азовсталі", називаючи її "евакуацією".
Тим не менш "Червоний хрест" реєстрував бійців як військовополонених.
Вони виходили на підконтрольну Росії територію.
Київ тепер сподівається повернути українських військових додому шляхом обміну.
Військова деблокада, на жаль, неможлива в цій ситуації.
І іншої формули порятунку, ніж та, яка використовується зараз, не може бути в цій ситуації.
Це був єдиний вихід.
Операція буде проводитися до повернення цих осіб на підконтрольну Україні територію.
Також у Києві наголошують на тому, що угруповання українських військ у Маріуполі
довгий час утримувало на собі російські війська.
Завдяки цьому вдалося стримати можливий наступ на інших ділянках фронту.
Європейські експерти поділяють таку думку.
Дійсно, ці бійці довго стягували на себе російські війська, змушуючи їх відбиватися,
і при цьому виграли час, аби Україна могла отримати західну зброю.
Вони виконали важливе військове завдання в стратегічному плані.
Припинення битви за "Азовсталь" експерти не оцінюють однозначно як перемогу чи поразку для обох сторін.
Росія не змогла проголосити символічне взяття Маріуполя. Натомість перетворила місто на згарище.
Тоді як Україна отримала своїх героїв, вважає британський експерт Філіпс О'Браєн.
Вони вже не тримали на собі значні російські сили останнім часом.
Вони були ціллю багатьох повітряних ударів, частково тому, що Маріуполь не був захищений з повітря.
Тож зараз у Росії звільниться частина повітряних сил, побачимо, як вони їх застосують.
З військової точки зору не думаю, що щось суттєво зміниться.
Росія вже вивела більшість своїх сил з Маріуполя.
Для української оборони це символічний, але не поворотний момент.
Тим часом подальша доля оборонців Маріуполя, серед яких і бійці полку "Азов", - під питанням.
Українці перебувають у виправній колонії в окупованій Оленівці, на території так званої "ДНР".
Російське міноборони поширює відео ролики, де українські військові розповідають про умови їхнього утримання.
Чи говорять вони зі своєї волі - перевірити неможливо.
Умови утримання - більш ніж достатні.
Матраци, ковдри є, харчування адекватне.
Вистачає і наїстися, і на все інше. Умови гарні.
Росія не підтверджує офіційно готовність до обміну.
Деякі західні експерти певні, що Москва може бути в ньому зацікавлена не менше, ніж Київ.
В Україні близько тисячі полонених росіян.
І я сподіваюся, Росія не буде намагатися ризикувати своїми полоненими.
Звісно, вивезення захисників "Азовсталі" на підконтрольні Росії території - не добрі новини,
але я сподіваюся українські лідери обдумали такий сценарій і змогли забезпечити те,
щоб нічого поганого не сталося з українськими полоненими.
Натомість спікер Держдуми В'ячеслав Володін назвав українських військових з "Азовсталі"
"нацистськими злочинцями" й заявив, що їхній обмін неприпустимий.
Верховний Суд Росії 26 травня розгляне подання Генпрокуратури
про визнання полку "Азов" "терористичною організацією".
Як зауважують юристи, формальні звинувачення "азовців" у тероризмі і надумані кримінальні провадження
дозволять Кремлю затягувати час і не обмінювати українців.
Утім, західні експерти наголошують на тому, що звинувачення на адресу українських бійців
не мають під собою реальних підстав.
Немає жодних документів та розслідувань, що доводять, що захисники Маріуполя нападали на мирних жителів,
бомбардували театри, де зовні було написано "діти". Мені від цього стає погано.
У Росії мають закликати до того, щоб військові злочини самих російських солдатів,
що відбуваються щодня, були розслідувані та передані до суду.
Російські солдати не мають етичного кодексу.
Масові вбивства, які ми спостерігали, або командування заплющує очі на них, або вони здійснюються за наказом.
При цьому західні аналітики не виключають, що над бійцями з "Азовсталі"
можуть влаштовувати показові суди заради пропаганди.
Я не виходжу з того, що в руках Росії - цінний об'єкт для обміну, я думаю, що це навіть більше.
Радше військовополонені потрібні для посилення аргументу боротьби з нацистами, і з цією метою їх використають.
Думаю, що Росії було дуже важливо захопити весь Маріуполь і отримати якнайбільше військовополонених з "Азовсталі",
тому що це зміцнює наратив Володимира Путіна про те, що він веде війну проти нацистів.
Не важливо при цьому, чи складається полк "Азов" насправді з нацистів, чи ні.
В українському міноборони заявляють, що агресивна риторика Росії призначена для "внутрішнього споживання".
Деталей запланованого обміну не коментують - надто чутливе питання.
Водночас Вікторія, яка чекає свого брата, вірить, що попри неоднозначні заяви за лаштунками тривають переговори.
Я не знаю, що там відбувається. Я не можу судити, це добре, чи погано.
Я себе заспокоюю тим, що це чудово, що тепер немає цих обстрілів, бомбардувань,
тобто якоюсь мірою він тепер у більш безпечному місці, але ця безпека дуже крихка.
Вікторія каже, що для неї одне випробування скінчилося, але тепер починається нове -
адже невідомо, що тепер чекає на бійців з "Азовсталі".